again earlier tonight the house voted to
formally authorize the Joe Biden
impeachment inquiry today uh the vote
came as a new poll showed an increase in
support for the gop's latest move here
with reaction Florida Governor 2024
Republican presidential candidate Ronda
Santos Governor great to have you back
um I'm still getting a lot of reaction
to the debate between you and Governor
Gavin Nome um when you look at the legal
troubles and the cognitive issues of Joe
Biden I know G Gavin said that you know
he he choose Joe Biden at a 100 over any
Republican okay um what do you see
happening do you think he survives
this well Sean I I I don't think we've
spoken um uh since that debate and the
reaction that I've gotten has been
incredible in terms of obviously being
able to show that freedom works and the
California models of failure what that
means for the country but people
appreciated the way you set it up and
they said it was the most substantive
debate that they've seen uh in this
entire election cycle and so kudos to
you for doing it I know you he had
challenged me and and you asked me to do
it so I'm glad we were able to get that
done uh and just know if you want to do
other debates uh Nikki Haley and me I'm
in Donald Trump and me I'm in so just
say the word uh you've shown that you
can do it and a way that I think really
helps the voters so uh I'm game just let
me know okay those are two do you have
any more on your list maybe Joe Mansion
he's going on a two-month tour anybody
else on your list that you'd like to
debate no I don't I don't think he's
going anywhere but I think on the Biden
thing so listen and this is part of the
reason why I thought it was important
that we do this Newsome debate obviously
there's a lot of Democrats that want to
remove him uh they understand the
liabilities they understand his his bad
policies uh I think he is not willing to
step down at this point but who knows
what's going to happen and I think this
inquiry is Justified I think it should
have been done long ago he's got so many
issues uh that are clouding his
presidency he clearly would not be a
great candidate for the Democrats so
Republicans uh we need to be ready for
whoever uh they pull out of the Hat Nome
has been waiting in the wings I mean
quite frankly after that debate I'm not
sure that that's the candidate they
would want because he embraced Biden
said Biden did an A+ job as president
are you kidding me but then he also is
saddled with all of his baggage in
California you have homelessness through
the roof crime pushing people out of
communities and even all the poop on the
street in San Francisco so I don't think
that they want to have to litigate on
two fronts to have to defend Biden's
failed policies and defend the failed
California policies but I do think we
have to be ready that it could be
someone else Governor uh I don't think
in all the years I've been doing this on
radio and TV I don't think I've ever
been as concerned as I am right now uh
about the state of our economy and the
state of the world and it is that I I
think we are living in consequential
times and this election is going to mean
everything and uh I I think one of the
issues if we don't get this if we don't
write this ship I don't even want to
think about what the consequences would
be and I'm sure that's what you think
about as
well well think about it we have a
government that's actively working
against hardworking Americans they're
working hard they can't get ahead
because of inflation interest rates
biomics the bureaucracy we have an open
border where 8 million people have come
since Biden's been president from all
over the world including the Middle East
we know that there are potential
terrorists that have come in that's made
the American people less safe less
secure we have fentanyl pouring into our
communities we have cities that are
collapsing San Francisco Los Angeles but
also Philly Chicago all these places
where obviously cities have always had
issue but they're becoming unlivable so
you have all these issues that are
compounding and then of course you have
China on the March uh you have war in
Israel versus uh Hamas and Biden is
trying to kneecap our great Ally Israel
so it really is a perfect storm and I
don't think I've seen anything like this
um in my lifetime and I think you'd
probably have to go back to the late
1970s under Jimmy Carter when our nation
was really suffering under the
cumulation of a lot of problems a lot of
people thought America's best days were
behind it then Ronald Reagan thought
differently I think we can reverse this
decline Sean but 2024 is Mak or break
you know that's why I thought the red
state blue State debate was so important
and and I'll be honest Governor I'm
getting out of New York I'm out of here
uh and uh Florida's right there at the
top let me know I have some conne at the
DMV in Florida I have connections at the
DMV I'll get your driver's license just
let me know all right I don't have to
wait online for four hours or 50 hours
like New York I'd appreciate it uh
anyway Governor great to see you we'll
get it that was a good debate and uh I I
will put out your challenge I promise
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else